اسمحوا لي أن
أسألكم السؤال الحقيقي الذي سمعت أنه يتم الحديث
عنه وقرأت أن الحديث عنه في
العالم العربي
هو هل قامت الإمارات والبحرين
ببيع الفلسطينيين ، بمعنى آخر ،
لم يكن هذا يعني
توفير ملايين
الفلسطينيين
من يعيشون في الأراضي المحتلة
مع نوع من الحقوق السياسية مع
دولة كانت السبب وراء
عدم اعتراف الدول العربية بإسرائيل
لعقود وعقود وأن الإمارات
والبحرين فعلتا ذلك دون أي تقدم
في القضية الفلسطينية ،
كيف رأيك؟  الشعور
السائد في الإمارات العربية المتحدة حول تلك
الجنية ، شكرًا لاستضافتي ، أعني
أولاً وقبل كل شيء
أن الفلسطينيين
يستحقون دولتهم
الخاصة وهي قضية
معترف بها عالميًا يقول القانون الدولي
أن المستوطنات في الأراضي
المحتلة
لا شيء غير قانوني
لم
يغيره الإمارات والبحرين في هذا الصدد ، والماراثيون واضحون للغاية
والشيخة بيلا بن زايد الميني الأجنبي.
أشار ستير في خطابه في البيت الأبيض خلال
حفل التوقيع
إلى هذه النقطة بالذات وقال إننا ندعم
حق الفلسطينيين في
دولة ، والمسألة هي أنه لم يتحرك أي شيء في
الاتجاه الصحيح بالنسبة للفلسطينيين
لعقود من الزمن
وقعوا على اتفاقيات أوسلو أكثر من
ربع.  من قرن مضى منذ
أن وقعت أي دولة عربية أي نوع من الاتفاق أو توصلت
إلى أي اتفاق مع الإسرائيليين ، على
العكس من ذلك ، فإن محنة الفلسطينيين
قد ازدادت سوءًا ،
لذا فإن السؤال هو هل هذا
يساعد بالفعل الوضع في الشرق الأوسط أم
لا
و  ما أوضحه الإماراتيون
هو أنه بالنسبة لهم أولاً وقبل كل
شيء ، كانت الخطوة المهمة للغاية من جانب الإسرائيليين
تتمثل في وقف ضم
الأراضي الفلسطينية
في مايو ويونيو من هذا العام هنا في
المنطقة ،
كنا جميعًا قلقين للغاية من أن
رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي
يمضي قدماً في قراره بضم
الأراضي الفلسطينية وضم وادي الأردن ،
الأمر الذي كان سيكون مروعًا
للفلسطينيين ولكن أيضًا للأردن.  دانيانز
ولكن في هذه الحالة يبدو أنه قد
تفوق على الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
فقد هدد بشيء لم يفعله أبدًا
وعاد لأنه
لم يفعل شيئًا لم يفعله أبدًا ،
وحصل على تنازل كبير من الإمارات العربية المتحدة ،
أعني أن هذا لا يعكس
جيدًا  على قيادة الإمارات
بشكل جيد ليس لأنه لم يفعل ذلك
لأنه كانت هناك محادثات قناة خلفية
تحدث ، أعني أن
سفير الإمارات العربية المتحدة لدى الولايات المتحدة يوسف لطيفه
قد خرج علنًا في يونيو وقال إن
أي خطوات نحو التطبيع
ستتوقف إذا استمر الضم.
لذلك كان من الواضح جدًا من الجانب الإماراتي
أن أيًا كان ما
كانت تفكر فيه دول الخليج سينتهي
إذا استمر الضم ، لذا أعتقد أنه
يتعين علينا رؤية التسلسل
هنا ، والعنصر الثاني الذي أعتقد أنه
مهم هو أنه
بالنسبة للفلسطينيين لا يزال يتعين عليهم العثور عليه
طريقة للحصول على دولتهم وهو
أمر لا تزال الإمارات العربية المتحدة فيه ، ولكن
بالطبع جميع الدول العربية
ملتزمة بمبادرة السلام العربية
التي كانت في عام 2002 ، فقد مرت 18 عامًا و
إنها
مشكلة حقيقية مع المجتمع الدولي
وفي المنطقة
حقيقة أنه لم يحدث شيء من
جانب مبادرة السلام العربية
حيث تم منح الإسرائيليين أمريكا
لأن إسرائيل لم تقبلها
ولماذا قبلتها إسرائيل لماذا
تقبلها منذ ذلك
الحين  كانت الجائزة في الفقرة في
مبادرة السلام العربية
اعترافًا بإسرائيل وهم كذلك ،
وقد قدمت الإمارات العربية المتحدة الجائزة
دون اعتراف إسرائيل بدولة فلسطينية ،
لذا
إذا كانوا يحصلون على المكافآت
دون تقديم حل وسط ، فلماذا
يقدمون التسوية
نعم  أعني ، انظر مرة أخرى ، لا تنس أن api
هي 57 دولة ،
لذا فهي أكثر من دولة أو دولتين
وبقدر ما يتعلق الأمر بالإماراتيين
وما يقولونه هنا
وما نسمعه من المسؤولين هنا
هو هذا بالنسبة لهم  كان قرارًا استراتيجيًا
بالنسبة لهم على الصعيد الثنائي مع
إسرائيل ولكن أيضًا بالنظر إلى
الشرق الأوسط والبحث في طرق كيف
يمكننا تغيير الركود الذي حدث.  لم
نشهد أي تطورات إيجابية نحو
السلام أو حتى
السماح للفلسطينيين بإحساس
تغيير الديناميكيات التي كانت لدينا
على الأرض